the starting gun is up ORS to front
stops
ready it was really important for us to
get rowing right just drop the blade in
Thomas okay World onls Ryan is the
ultimate team sport everybody has to do
exactly the same thing at exactly the
same
time for the first 6 weeks we were
training training started in a
controlled environment in this tank
where everybody just figured out the
Rhythm and then that transitioned onto
the river we get picked up at 6:30 it
was wake up roll eat sleep repeat wet
and cold best part of the day right here
a massive amount of rowing on the river
temps that's it's also a lot of
conditioning work in the
gym it's like having eight people try to
learn how to drive at 100 mph sharing
one steering wheel so when George and I
went to go in the first time and they're
rowing I mean they were horrible it was
just like paddles going everywhere relax
those shoulders about 4 weeks later they
were rolling as as a team good we would
train whenever we had days off
throughout filming and we push ourselves
and push each other to go as fast as we
can we shot in order so by the time we
got to the race in
Germany our kids could stay in the game
give me 46 yesterday we got to 46 which
is the amount of Strokes per minute you
have in the boat which is what the boys
did in the Olympics to win the race and
I couldn't be prouder of all of us for
all the people who didn't believe in you
one as
[Music]
one